[Musique]
en
excellent mercredi à toutes et à tous
bienvenue sur rt france info décryptage
invités analyse c'est parti pour deux
heures d'émission tout de suite les
titres à la perspective d'un confinement
plus que jamais d'actualité même sous
une forme très serré selon la sémantique
du porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent évoque plusieurs scénarios
l'imbroglio perdure donc confusion
ambiante également autour de la faible
productivité des vaccins pour l'europe a
[Musique]
prises de paroles inédites depuis 12 ans
cet après-midi de vladimir poutine au
forum économique de davos le chef du
kremlin se pose en chantre de la
stabilité globale et appelle à une
meilleure atmosphère générale mondiale
et ce au lendemain d'un entretien
téléphonique avec joe biden qui permet
de prolonger le traité new start sur les
armes nucléaires incertitudes politiques
en tunisie au lendemain d'un remaniement
ministériel approuvé par le parlement
avec en toile de fond une contestation
populaire qui ne faiblit pas depuis la
mi janvier le dixième anniversaire de la
révolution de jasmin les manifestations
se succèdent pour appeler à une
meilleure politique sociale
[Musique]
énième conseil de défense sanitaire ce
matin et les premières conclusions
laissent peu de doute sur ce qui attend
une nouvelle fois les français plus de
précisions tout de suite avec nadège
abderrazak en direct de l'elysée nadège
après cette énième conseil de défense
sanitaire est ce qu'on en sait un peu
plus sur ce qui attend les français
ce conseil de défense ans est devenu le
rituel du mercredi pour l'exécutif pad
annonce majeure à l'issue de ce nouveau
rendez vous les autorités disent comme
depuis le début de la semaine attendre
de connaître d'abord les effets du
couvre-feu à 18 heures instaurée partout
en france depuis une dizaine de jours
pour pouvoir se prononcer
des effets qui devrait être visible à
partir de samedi
mais les indicateurs sont au rouge à en
croire le porte parole du gouvernement
d'après gabriel attal le couvre-feu à
18h à une efficacité relative et ne
freine pas suffisamment la propagation
du virus et donc plusieurs scénarios
serait donc envisager ce sont plusieurs
scénarios qui vont d'un maintien du
cadre actuel avec le couvre-feu à 18h
jusqu'à un confinement très serré ces
différents scénarios ont été abordés ce
matin et je rappelle que le président de
la république a demandé au gouvernement
des analyses complémentaires
épidémiologique et scientifique sur
chacun de ces scénarios et que dans le
même temps des concertations vont être
menées par le premier ministre à la
demande du président de la république
avec le comité de liaison parlementaires
les groupes parlementaires représentés
au parlement avec les partenaires
sociaux et les associations d'élus
ces concertations approfondies vont se
dérouler dans les tout prochains jours
tient du couvre-feu ou troisième
confinement n'en sait pas vraiment plus
pour le moment ce que l'on sait elle
sait qu emmanuel macron souhaite éviter
leur confinement pourquoi parce que le
président de la république sait qu'il
joue gros politiquement et pas sûr que
les français se soumettent une nouvelle
fois d'ailleurs le phénomène de
désobéissance civile inquiète aux plus
hautes sphères de l'état
il y un phénomène de lassitude de doute
de questionnement et tout ça est
légitime et dans la décision politique
vous devez prendre en compte
l'acceptation sociale
on est sur un terrain glissant le risque
en refermant le pays
c'est la désobéissance civile de
certains
ce soir un nouveau dîner de travail
devait avoir lieu à l'elysée avec
emmanuel macron jean castex le premier
ministre et tous les responsables de la
majorité
alejo m et modem un dîner de travail qui
a finalement été annulée à la dernière
minute pour éviter toute polémique
autour du non respect du couvre-feu à
18h ou des gestes barrières demain
olivier vers on doit tenir une
conférence de presse il devrait s'agir
d'un simple bilan sanitaire hebdomadaire
comme était habituelle faire le ministre
de la santé en 2020
sauf coup de théâtre il ne devrait donc
pas y avoir d'annoncé majeure cette
semaine merci nadège abderrazak pour
toutes ces précisions en direct du
palais présidentiel à paris couvre feu
généralisé à 18h confinement souple ou
très serré on en parle avec djillali
annane chef du service réanimation à
l'hôpital raymond-poincaré de garches
dans les hauts-de-seine
c'est notre rubrique invité
bonsoir djillali annane merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
est ce matin sur le plateau d'une autre
chaîne télé vous avez déclaré je cite
vous êtes prévenu que le tsunami arrive
sur la plage et vous décidé de laisser
les gens sur cette plage au motif qu il
fait encore beau mais avant qu'il ya un
tsunami les sismologues alerte un
tremblement de terre or là les
scientifiques les politiques
on a l'impression que c'est la
cacophonie bonsoir
encore une fois ce qui est clair c'est
que ce que nous observons sur le terrain
tous les jours
1 c'est une dynamique de plus en plus
positive de l'épidémie qui commence
d'ailleurs probablement à être en partie
expliquer cette dynamique très positive
par l'installation du variant
britannique qui par exemple en ile de
france représente pratiquement 20%
aujourd'hui des cas de contamination et
on voit que ça
son installation est de plus en plus
rapide et qu'il va prendre le train il
doit être la locomotive de l'épidémie
dans les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines et on a vu à quel point
en angleterre les ce virus ce variant
pardon du virus peut faire mettre très
attention le système hospitalier et
aboutir à une situation plus dégradée
non seulement que celle que nous vivons
aujourd'hui mais que celle que nous
avons vécue il ya un an on parlait de la
grande bretagne qui est donc confiné le
couvre-feu à 18h ne freine pas
suffisamment l'épidémie ans selon
gabriel atta le porte parole a évoqué ce
matin un confinement très serré parmi
les scénarios c'est quoi c'est préparer
la population à une nouvelle mise sous
cloche ou bien c noyer le poisson quand
il parle de plusieurs options en tout
cas ce qui est démontré maintenant c'est
que effectivement le coup le couvre-feu
et son avancement à 18 heures n'a pas
permis de d'infléchir la courbe des
contaminations ça à peine réussi à
freiner ces contaminations alors même
que le variant britannique n'assure pas
encore la locomotive de l'épidémie on
voit bien que le couvre-feu y compris
avancé à 18h s'avère
malheureusement insuffisant c'est ce
qu'a dit ghislain rosier de kobe tracker
il a dit au mieux le couvre-feu à 18
heures a eu un effet modéré au pire il
n'a pas été efficace se veut dire quoi
au final qu'on a perdu quinze jours
c'est ça pourtant comme le président du
conseil scientifique jean françois
delfraissy a dit on n'est pas à trois
jours près il faut savoir on s'y perd un
peu
non mais en tout cas moi je faisais
partie de ceux qui recommandait dès le
26 décembre à que l'euro que l'on prenne
décision stricte de leur confinement
pour justement essayer au maximum
d'éviter l'installation du variant
britannique sur le territoire c'étaient
des mesures différentes votées priest
est un pari osé qui aujourd'hui ce pari
était perdu donc la question à mon avis
des pucelles de faut-il confiné au pain
mais plus précisément comment réussir le
confinement pas simplement sur le plan
sanitaire mais également sur le plan de
ses conséquences économiques sociales et
de comment on peut les atténuer le plus
possible et comment comment faire pour
ce confinement sur les plus courts
possibles
justement djillali annane j'allais venir
le vin alliance est donc cette épidémie
dans dans l'épi dans l'épidémie qui
impose un strict confinement d'après ce
que ce que vous nous dites mais à quel
prix pour la population parce qu'elle
est la santé mentale des des français il
ya l'économie d'ailleurs hier sur notre
antenne y avait jean guillaume daret de
la confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprises
il nous disait qu'une entreprise sur
deux serait dans l'incapacité dont durée
un troisième confinement vous comprenez
les difficultés à la fois psychologique
et économique
absolument mais la situation dans
laquelle on se trouve aujourd'hui avec
les mesures qui sont aujourd'hui en
vigueur
on voit bien que ces mesures en bio
aujourd'hui induisent une souffrance
considérables tout un secteur d'activité
ne peut pas redémarrer et ces mesures là
ne permettent pas de contrôler
l'épidémie
ce qui veut dire que si on en reste à
ces mesures et bien cela date durer
encore des semaines et des mois sans
espoir de reprendre ses activités
donc en réalité le couvre-feu strict
rapide et de courte durée est
pratiquement la meilleure garantie pour
tout ce secteur d'activité a géré ça
veut dire en même temps c'est
probablement si on le confie dès
maintenant alors qu'on est à 25000
contamination par jour et
un confinement de trois semaines serait
probablement suffisant si on attend de
monter à 60 milles contamination par
jour et qu'on attend que le variant
britanniques représentent plus de 50% du
des soul circulantes en france alors il
faudra confiné six semaines voyez la
portance de décision rapide
c'est que elle doit aussi impacter sur
la durée du confinement vous dites 50%
faudrait six semaines en ce moment vous
avez évoqué 20 % en ile-de-france on est
entre 10 et 20 % 14 selon certains
chiffres de contaminer donc qu'ils sont
par le variant britannique du strass cov
de la fameuse souche b 1 1,7 à quoi
s'attendre dans quelques semaines avec
une telle contagiosité un scénario à
l'anglais ce vous l'avez parlez vous en
avait parlé il ya quelques instants
pourtant nous français on porte les
masques c'est une arme supplémentaire
non parce que les britanniques ne
portent pas notamment le masque à
l'extérieur non mais c'est clair que les
français respectent les gestes barrière
là-dessus dia il n'y a pas de doute
la difficulté c'est que ce variant est
malheureusement beaucoup plus contagieux
que la souche original et donc ça veut
dire quoi qu'il est plus contagieux ça
veut dire qu'il met en défaut plus
facilement les gestes barrière c'est
pour ça que la distanciation physique a
été allongé de 1 m à 2 m et donc
malheureusement le gagnant britannique
et je vous rappelle on était à peine 1 à
3%
début janvier des cas contaminés duo
vaillant britannique
aujourd'hui on est probablement au
niveau national à plus de 10% pour ce
qui veut dire qu'on a peine quinze jours
le variant britannique a été vu sa
prévalence a été multiplié par dix donc
il est très vraisemblable qu'on soit
effectivement ici quinze jours avec plus
de 50% détaillant britannique circulant
en france après plus de 50 % des cas de
contamination représenté par le drian
britannique
ça montre à quel point ce variant se
propage très vite et il est clair qu'il
va devenir la souche dominante et est
important de réagir pour le freiner le
plus possible et le confinement reste là
la mesure la plus crédible pour assurer
et garantir cette efficacité
merci jelly annan d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
chef du service de réanimation à
l'hôpital raymond-poincaré de garches
flou ambiant donc autour d'un éventuel
reconfirme en confusion également au
sujet des vaccins après les retards de
livraison chez pfizer biotech place au
bras de fer entre astrazeneca et l'union
européenne
le laboratoire britannique et bruxelles
qui s'invectivent à distance maxima vers
le bras de fer dure depuis plusieurs
jours alors qu astrazeneca annoncé
vendredi une baisse de 60% de ses
livraisons vers l'union européenne les
vingt-sept sommes désormais le
laboratoire de lui fournir comme convenu
les 80 millions de doses commandées les
27 membres de l'union européenne sont
d'accord sur le fait qu'astra zika doit
respecter les livraisons stipulé dans le
contrat
le noeud du problème c'est bien ce
contrat encore confidentiel dans l'union
européenne la fabrication du vaccin est
assurée aux pays bas et en belgique
mais ces deux sites ont la productivité
la plus faible du réseau selon pascal
soriot pourtant l'union européenne la
sueur dans le contrat y est stipulé que
le laboratoire doit compenser le manque
de rendement de ses usines européennes
par des doses fabriquées au royaume uni
1.2 contre a démenti formellement dans
plusieurs journaux européens mardi par
le pdg d'astrazeneca
nous ne nous sommes aucunement engagée
auprès de lieux
on a dit on fera de notre mieux mais
sans garantie de réussir lieu voulait
plus ou moins autant de vaccins que le
royaume uni alors qu'il signait trois
mois après londres a stipulé que
l'approvisionnement provenant de la
chaîne d'approvisionnement britannique
irait d'abord au royaume uni il est
mentionné que les sites de fabrication
britannique était une option pour
l'europe mais seulement plus tard
problème les états membres ont dépensé
beaucoup 336 millions d'euros et sont
sous pression alors que d'autres
laboratoires comme pfizer ont également
réduit leur livraison en filigrane lui
accuse astrazeneca de favoriser la
production et la distribution de doses à
destination du royaume uni alors que les
dirigeants européens comptaient sur ces
doses moins chers et dont la
conservation est plus simple que celle
de ses concurrents le fait que
l'entreprise ne soit pas obligé de nous
livrer car nous aurions accepté qu'elle
fasse de son mieux
ce n'est ni correct ni acceptable
qu'elle ne soit pas capable d'assurer la
fabrication va à l'encontre de notre
accord nous rejetons la loi du premier
arrivé premier servi
astrazeneca devait se justifier devant
la commission ce mercredi mais le
laboratoire anglo-suédois quitté la
réunion selon plusieurs dirigeants son
vaccin doit encore être homologué en
europe alors même que des doutes
subsistent quant à son efficacité sur
les populations âgées
cible principale des plans de
vaccination européen
de son côté pascal soriot assurée qu'à
partir de février 17 % de la capacité de
production de ses usines seraient
mobilisés pour l'europe
le vaccin d'astrazeneca conscient
partenariat avec l'université d'oxford
et plus faciles à déployer que les deux
autres faillir biotech et moderna mais
en attente de son homologation en europe
quels seront ses recommandations pour
quelle classe d'âge les retards de
livraison également vont-ils contraindre
la france à revoir sa stratégie
vaccinale c'est le décryptage et nous
inviter florian philippot le président
des patriotes et elle jean philippe
dugoin clément lemaire udi de mennessis
dans l'essonne et vice-président de la
région ile-de-france bonsoir messieurs
merci de répondre à nos questions sur
arte france on vient de le voir avec le
sujet de maxime abers la confusion règne
sur la production et la livraison de
vaccins astrazeneca pour l'europe mais
il ya aussi des retards de livraison de
kaiser biotech notamment d'ailleurs la
suède suspendant le paiement des vaccins
à pfizer pour un faute de livraisons
astrazeneca qui soit dit en passant est
un laboratoire britanno suédois vous qui
êtes anti européen florian philippot ça
veut dire qu'il faut que la france fasse
comme la suède suspende également le
paiement
sa cible et ça me paraît être la moindre
des choses c'est à dire que il faut même
aller plus loin que ça en fait on a
appris ce matin j'ai écouté une radio de
service public qui a révélé que la
commission européenne a accepté début
janvier de payer 6 12 pour ce que les
soignants en fait tu considères comme ça
il paraît plus par des soignants
d'arriver à faire que cinq doses et non
pas six avec le faiza au bio in tech et
donc pourquoi la commission européenne a
accepté ça une vraie question ça suis
saoul et ça commence à faire beaucoup
parce que ça suit le scandale du rem
désir en octobre
la commission européenne a acheté pour 1
milliard d'euros de lorraine daisy on
savait le médicament de gila devons
conserver en fait déjà à l'époque qu'il
était parfaitement inefficace contre le
19 voire dangereux dans certains effets
secondaires et pourtant l'union
européenne a fait un chèque avec notre
argent d'un milliard d'euros pour ce
médicament inefficace inutile et très
cher donc il ça mérite des enquêtes soul
et au delà de suspendre le paiement si
la moindre des choses
devant ce fiasco général de l'union
européenne ça mérite qu'on sache est ce
qu'il ya des problèmes des cons problème
de liens de conflit d'intérêts avec ces
laboratoires faudrait creuser parce que
ça commence à s'accumuler et ça donne à
réfléchir quand même sur cette étrange
commission européenne qui passe de très
gros contrats avec le simple d'un point
selon un responsable européen deux
usines astrazeneca devraient quand même
produire des vaccins pour lieu au
royaume uni tout de même l'union
européenne a rappelé hier les
investissements massifs de l'europe
envers les fabriquons l'a rappelé
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui même
jean philippe dugoin clément vous qui
êtes pro européen comment contraindre
les fabricants à honorer leurs
engagements et est ce que vous croyez
que les laboratoires favorise d'autres
marchés plutôt que le vieux continent
le sujet c'est pas l'union européenne
sait on est confronté à des laboratoires
qui ont des méthodes de bandits qui sont
dans des logiques c'est chaque conflit a
eu ces profiteurs et on a des
laboratoires qui ont des attitudes de
profiteurs ce que fait pizer biotech
c'est pas compliqué c'est les soignants
se sont rendu compte qu'on pouvait
arriver à sortir jusqu'à 6 doses par
rapport aux flacons qui étaient livrés
et donc six heures qui a passé un
contrat effectivement sur un nombre de
doses et pas sur une quantité de vaccins
et biens diminuent de 20% ses
approvisionnements et donc facture là où
il y avait douze flacons qui était amené
va être amené à ne plus en livrer que
dix ça contribue à alimenter la pénurie
et c'est quelque chose de profondément
inacceptable et je pense que l'italie il
contrats qui ont été signés ça veut dire
que les contrats ont mal été élaboré il
ya effectivement un noeud faiblesse de
contrats probablement et il y a une
attitude qui est absolument scandaleuse
scandaleuse de la part de pfizer
parce que la réalité quand vous discutez
avec des soignants sur le prélèvement
qui est fait certains arrivent à sortir
cinq doses mais pas tous
selon la technicité employés le type de
seringue employés l'habitude du soignant
de faire des prélèvements
beaucoup d'entre eux n'arrive pas à
sortir la 6e dos on a très clairement
sur une question de santé publique
majeur dans une situation qui est une
situation de crise majeure
un laboratoire qui serge qui cherchent à
sur marges et sur les pauvres gens sur
les gens qui attendent ce ce soin c'est
quelque chose qui est inacceptable
je pense que les états l'europe mais les
états un des individus helmand doivent
aussi un moment réaffirmé la puissance
publique
nous n'avons pas à supporter ou à
tolérer que des entreprises sur marge
surface du bénéfice au sur le dos de la
santé publique
encore une fois à moi sur le laboratoire
français sanofi qui va
devenir un sous traitant justement de
pfizer biotech envoyer la réaction ce
matin du président de la branche
française du géant pharmaceutique
c'est une première et j'en suis pas peu
fier parce que quand vous êtes dans une
crise comme celle ci où vous devez pour
retrouver une vie normale vacciner un
grand nombre de personnes
être en capacité de produire et ça va
être le cas pour sanofi avec bio ntech
100 millions de doses ça veut dire
vacciner 50 millions de personnes
ça veut peut-être dire protéger 50
millions de personnes et sauver des vies
ces deux elles vont arriver à partir de
l'été jusqu'à la fin de l'année en six
mois on va être en capacité de produire
ces 100 millions de doses sanofi sous
traitants de son concurrent opération
louable d'un côté mais tellement
regrettable d'un autre sachant que le
groupe a annoncé des licenciements et
que son vaccin ne serait prêt que pour
la fin 2021 florian philippot comment
est-ce que vous accueillez toutes ces
informations au sujet de sanofi dire que
je pars à dire simplement que le finder
et le grand méchant enfin l'union
européenne et qu'on puisse totalement de
saâles assigné élaboré ces contrats
comme vous le rappeliez et en fait on
voit bien pourquoi on nous pousse vers
cette stratégie vaccinale uniquement et
qu'on néglige les traitements les
médicaments les vieilles molécules qui
elles ne rapportent pas on est là union
n en parlent évidemment jamais il ya une
complicité totale entre l'industrie
pharmaceutique et l'union européenne
et ça je crois qu'il faut absolument le
soulever les problèmes de conflit
d'intérêt voire pire pour le reste sur
sanofi image aux joueurs je me désole
simplement qu'en france on est des
chercheurs on a les chercheurs qui parle
depuis le début de cette crise on les
négligent
voilà je pense au professeur raoul tu je
pense à d'autres qui sont considérés
comme les meilleurs dans leur discipline
au monde et on les a mis de côté et on a
eu lui on avait une industrie
pharmaceutique qui était de pointe et on
l'a également laissé tomber on l'a pas
on n'a pas investi on n'a pas fait ce
qu'il fallait on m'a résultat
aujourd'hui on est déclassé mais c'est
pas que sanofi
il a atteint 2 qui va devoir travailler
pour ses concurrents c'est en général la
recherche française soit elle a été
victime de sous investissement
d'austérité rapidement délétère soit
pour des raisons idéologiques
depuis le début de cette crise qu vide
on met de côté nos brillants chercheurs
de brillant médecin et d'ailleurs qui
nos médecins libéraux au passage on ne
les écoute pas là aussi pour des raisons
qui mériterait d'être éclaircis parce
que cette date est obscur et sombre et
les résultats de la france se retrouve
dans une situation dramatique où elle
apparaît comme n'ayant pas la capacité
de répondre convenablement à cette crise
on fait n'importe quoi on fait des
couvre-feux déconfinement ont détruit le
pays ont détruit nos libertés et on ne
fait pas confiance à nos médecins et à
nos chercheurs
voilà moi ce que je retiens de cette
situation jean philippe dugoin clément
sanofi bon samaritain ou calculateur
opportuniste opportuniste sanofi vient
d'annoncer le licenciement de 400
personnels enfin on a ou payent dans ce
pays on paye au niveau européen parce
que ce qui est vrai en france on le
retrouve dans tous les autres pays
européens on paye là désinscrit la
désindustrialisation dans le domaine
pharmaceutique entre autres pour ne
citer que ce nous ici et on continue
dans cette logique là en affaiblissant
laissant un certain nombre de fleurons
de ce qui devrait être des garanties
d'indépendance pour notre pays pour
notre continent et bien continuer à
s'affaiblir
moi je suis effectivement triste que
sanofi n'est pas tu aller au bout de ses
premières expérimentations alors on nous
parle d'autres expérimentations qui sont
en cours très bien la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nous nous rendons compte
que dans le domaine sanitaire dans le
domaine pharmaceutique nous sommes
dépendants notre pays notre continent a
réussi dans des domaines qu'ils
considéraient comme prioritaire je pense
à l'armement par exemple à rester
indépendants à garder une capacité
industrielle on à accepter de la perdre
au cours de ces trente quarante
dernières années dans le domaine médical
dans le domaine pharmaceutique est bien
l'un des enseignements c'est qu'on ne
doit plus accepter ça et on doit ré
industrialiser on doit réinvestir
massivement
c'est une volonté des pouvoirs publics
qui doivent être mises en oeuvre
c'est aussi des choix politiques qui
doivent être mises en oeuvre
il faut pas se leurrer ses choix
politiques on ne pourra pas les porter
seul haut niveau franco français sur un
pays de 70 millions d'habitants
on pourra les porter en travaillant
ensemble à plusieurs
parce que la réalité des masses quand on
parle canton
je compare à l'inde un milliard
d'habitants quand on se compare à la
chine 1 milliards soit un milliard deux
cent mille habitants
et bien la réalité c'est que si on veut
avoir des seuils critiques
on ne pourra pas le porter tout seul
donc effectivement il ya un besoin
d'indépendance arts créée il ya un
besoin de ré industrialisation
on doit de fer de lance nous français là
dessus mais on doit le faire au niveau
européen
messieurs je reviens sur le vaccin
astrazeneca qui devait et il devrait
être homologué par l'agencé européenne
du médicament vendredi voire même demain
l'enjeu porte moins sur son approbation
que sur les recommandations qui
accompagneront cette décision puisque
les moins de 65 ans pourraient être
écartés des recommandations pour pour ce
sérum alors qu'en france la stratégie
vaccinale
ce sont les plus de 70 ans et qui sont
prioritaires si l'efficacité de ce
vaccin chez les seniors se révèle être
insuffisante aux yeux de la même
l'agencé européenne du médicament la
stratégie vaccinale de nombreux pays
dont la france serait alors remis en
cause non florian philippot bon de toute
façon on navigue dans des eaux troubles
depuis le début puisque je vous rappelle
que les travailleurs et modern assez de
thérapie génique n'ont pas été testés
dans les essais cliniques sur les plus
de 75 ans voilà donc les taux
d'efficacité est faramineux qui ont été
avancées là les 95 94 5%
elles ne sont pas vrai puisque ça n'a
pas été fait notamment sur la population
la plus âgée la plus à risque on sait
qu'elle moins de réponses immunitaires
le astrazeneca on apprend des choses
effectivement vous l'avez rappelé
masquer ce qui est hallucinant si vous
voulez c'est que on notera on ne mise
pas aller sur la prévention ni sur le
traitement fin du mois j'ai vu comme
vous les cultes que la presse a relayé
l'appel des 73 médecins français et six
associations médicales très sérieuse
pour la vitamine d en termes de
prévention
ça a été celle utilisée dans plein de
pays dans le monde ça a été prouvé par
ses médecins est-ce que vers ans en est
saisi
pas une seule seconde à 8 secondes même
chose sur fait la colchicine avec
l'étude canadienne en double aveugle est
sorti cette semaine que qui a été relayé
également par eux par la fp la presse
française bon on n'en parle pas alors
évidemment ce sont des traitements qui
utilisent des molécules qui ne rapporte
rien mais je suis fasciné de voir que
dans notre pays c'est soit soient tous à
la maison
assigné à résidence soit le passeport
sanitaire la stratégie vaccinale et au
milieu la prévention aux traitements
personne n'en parle voilà c'était de la
fin le mot de la fin rapidement
jean philippe dugoin traitement on a
quinze secondes
écoutez là dessus oui on est sur une
stratégie on voit qu'on navigue à vue qu
on a un gouvernement qui ne puis un an a
manqué de colonne vertébrale a manqué
n'a pas su donner un cap et je pense
qu'il est important enfin que nous
puissions donner des perspectives aux
français si on n'est pas capable de
donner des perspectives aux français si
la seule réponse c'est un confinement
numéro 3 quand je crains énormément
qu'on aille sur des risques de
désobéissance civile généralisée on l'a
vu à nice aujourd'hui on le voit aux
pays bas je crois qu'on est sur un corps
social qui est à bout et on doit arriver
à donner des perspectives si on ne fait
pas ça je suis très inquiet pour
l'avenir à court terme
merci à tous les deux d'avoir répondu à
nos questions florian philippot je
rappelle que vous êtes le président des
patriotes et jean philippe dugoin
clément vous êtes le vice-président du
délit de la région ile-de-france est
juste un petit mot
la majorité a l'air om a voté la fin de
la mission d'information de l'assemblée
nationale sur la gestion de l'épidémie
de covile 19 les oppositions dénonce je
cite un coup de force et une absence de
débat contradictoire rester sur rt
france dans un instant gros plan sur le
sommet de davos virtuelle cette année
pandémie de courant des virus oblige la
demeure comptines s'est exprimé
aujourd'hui une première depuis 2009 et
puis un focus sur la tunisie où les
manifestations perdure au lendemain d'un
remaniement ministériel contesté a tout
de suite
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que le légat fans ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur gallois peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom est dans l'hymne
quel rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a
vu et big for donc les gaffes à
s'organiser pour annuler quelqu'un sur
internet ce quelqu'un c'était donald
trump quand il s'agit d'un bannissement
si général pour moi ce n'est pas aux
gaffes à et aux réseaux sociaux hanul à
des entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui compte là on
soit vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on est une gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
très bonne soirée à toutes et à tous
bienvenue sur rt france si vous nous
rejoignez il est 20h30 heure française
troisième jour du 51e forum économique
de davos un rendez-vous a entièrement
virtuelle cette année coville 19 oblige
avec pour thème une année cruciale pour
rebâtir la confiance la crise sanitaire
évoqué cet après-midi par vladimir
poutine
il s'agit de sa première intervention à
ce sommet depuis douze ans le chef du
kremlin qui se posent en chantre de la
stabilité globale en appelant à une
normalisation des relations entre la
russie et l'europe entre moscou et
washington également avec la maîtrise
des armements nucléaires
la correspondance d'antoine claireaux
dans la capitale russe il a largement
été question dans son intervention de la
pandémie que nous traversons ainsi que
de ses conséquences sur nos sociétés
vladimir poutine la crise sanitaire
renforce les déséquilibres en
particulier sur le plan social
c'est d'ailleurs le premier défi qu'il a
identifié le défis socio-économiques
en effet la crise a causé disparités
importantes dans certains pays
occidentaux la part de la population qui
vit sous le seuil de pauvreté a même
augmenté ces déséquilibres provoque donc
d'après vladimir poutine
une intolérance un mécontentement social
et favorise le populisme la montée des
extrêmes à gauche comme à droite
votre sujet délicat équilibre à trouver
concernant le respect de la vie privée
sur internet
en effet vladimir poutine estime que
dorénavant les géants du numérique sont
à même de concurrencer des états sur
certains aspects
troisième défi celui des relations entre
les états le président russe déplore les
sanctions visant certains pays et plaide
pour la mise en place d' un monde
véritablement multipolaire et cela passe
notamment par la conclusion d'accords de
traité de désarmement ya le problème de
la sécurité internationale et monsieur
choix vous venez de parler de
l'entretien que j'ai eu hier avec le
président bailly donne
sur la prorogation des traités et des
accords qui avaient essayé mais malgré
cela il ya quand même un certain nombre
de contradictions qui demeurent dans le
monde
le manque de volonté de résoudre ces
problèmes peut-être un défi important
ici dans notre siècle et lien j'espère
bien sûr qu'il n'y aura pas de grand
conflit mondial qui vont déclencher la
fin de la sécurisation
mais malgré tout la situation peut
évoluer de façon imprévisible on entendu
nous allons prendre le magnifique
maximum de mesures pour éviter que cela
se produise mais enfin il faut être
confiant que il faut être conscient que
tout cela peut se produire à avoir une
influence sur l'évolution de notre monde
malgré tous ces défis vladimir poutine
incite ses partenaires à rester
optimiste et a cherché des approches
communes pour mettre fin au différend
pour illustrer ses propos il a pris les
exemples des conflits entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan ou encore celui de syrie
autant de dossiers où le dialogue et la
coopération ont réussi à faire taire le
bruit des armes et de dialogue et de
coopération
il doit aussi en être question entre
l'europe et la russie
mais ce qui est important ici c'est
qu'il faut procéder à un dialogue direct
entre nous se débarrassait des phobies
du passé ne pas s'appuyer sur les pas se
servir des processus politiques internes
qui héritait des siècles précédents mais
regarder ensemble l'avenir ici nous
savons nous redresser au-dessus de ses
phobies
à ce moment là effectivement nous sommes
à une étape positive
de nos échanges et nous le voulons nous
le souhaitons nous y sommes prêts
l'amour n'est pas possible si s'il n'est
pas partagée s'il n'est que dans un sens
il faut la réciprocité conclure le
président russe a jugé que pour
atteindre une certaine stabilité et
permettre le développement des pays de
façon harmonieuse quatre priorités
doivent être dressé l'accès de chacun à
un logement à l'éducation
un travail et aux soins voilà donc ce
qu'on peut retenir de sa prise de parole
prendre davantage en compte l'aspect
social de cette crise et l'appel à la
coopération internationale et on
continue de parler coopération
internationales et diplomatie avec
l'aude ou blanche maison expert en
relations internationales
bonsoir club blanchemaison merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
qu'est ce que vous retenez de la prise
de parole de vladimir poutine au forum
de davos
je crois que c'est une intervention
importante
d'abord parce que comme vous l'avez dit
le dr poutine n'a pas participé au forum
de davos depuis 2009
en deuxième lieu parceque il a fait une
analyse très précise de la crise
économique actuelle due à la pandémie du
coc u19 qui convergent absolument avec
ce que disent tous les grands
responsables mondiaux
que ce soient des responsables
politiques ou le fmi ou la banque
mondiale
en troisième lieu parce qu'il a pris la
défense des organisations multilatérales
en disant qu'elle était essentielle pour
résoudre les problèmes du temps et puis
enfin parce qu'il appuie les propos très
positifs sur l'europe
alors vous avez fait je crois un très
bon résumé dans votre sujet de la du
diagnostic que veut dire petite pause
cela sur la crise économique et il a en
effet beaucoup insisté sur le fait que
les inégalités croissantes à l'intérieur
des états et entre les états étaient
extrêmement dommageable parce qu'elle
poussait à l'intérieur des états à la
montée des extrêmes extrême gauche et
extrême droite et entre les états à la
poussée du nationalisme tout cela
générateur de conflits et par conséquent
il a appelé en effet à
prendre des politiques qui permettent de
réduire ces inégalités pour lutter
contre la tendance actuelle
il a aussi parlé bien sûr des cafards
qui viennent en concurrence avec les
états et qu'il convient maintenant de
réguler par conséquent il y à une
régulation par les états ou par une
instance internationale de leur activité
par ailleurs il a appelé à une relance
de l'économie en faisant appel à
l'entrepreneuriat en faisant appel à la
société civile en revente appel aux
forces vives des différentes nations le
président russe qui insiste sur la
relation également entre la russie et
l'europe
ce rapprochement est ce qu'il est
réaliste alors la libertine parle de
3par de trois constatations de trois
réalités il dit la russie et l'europe
partagent la même culture
elle partage deuxièmement la même
civilisation et troisièmement elles ont
des intérêts économiques convergent
parce qu'elles sont complémentaires et
d'ailleurs l'union européenne et reste
la première le premier partenaire
économique de la russie
donc pour toutes ces raisons on voit pas
pourquoi il y aurait le moindre divorce
entre la russie et l'union européenne il
a rappelé que dans les années 2000 on
avait discuté d'un espace commun entre
la russie et l'union européenne
il aurait pu se décliner d'ailleurs sur
divers que sur divers aspects la
connaissance l'économie la sécurité
évidemment il a il a ajouté qu' il
fallait être deux pour avancer et que
l'amour devait être partagé je crois que
c'est l'expression qui l'a utilisé et
que pour que cela fonctionne il fallait
repartir à zéro c'est d'aller rennie
réinitialiser les relations entre
l'europe et la russie et mettre entre
parenthèses les sujets qui fâchent ou
qui nous ont fâché au cours des
dernières années ce qui naturellement
sera sujet à discussion à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne parce que certains
états pensent qu'il est difficile de
mettre entre parenthèses les difficultés
qui sont présentés notamment en ukraine
et que la plupart des états considèrent
qu'il faut de toute façon observé les
traités internationaux et notamment ceux
des natures unis il prévoit de respecter
les droits de l'homme comme l'enjeu
maison coville 19 oblige c'est un davos
virtuel à 1 cette année
mais un deuxième se tiendra en mai à
singapour en présentiel cette fois ci
les conditions sanitaires le permettent
de forum économique coup sur coup ça
peut accélérer le dénouement de certains
dossiers
oui peut-être en tout cas ça montre deux
choses ça montre que les gens qui
participent actuellement au forum de
davos attache beaucoup d'importance aux
relations personnelles comme on dit à
davos et comme on dit également à
singapour
le networking tisser des liens tissés
des réseaux et pour cela il faut qu'une
réunion se déroule en présentiel et le
deuxième la deuxième conclusion qu'on
peut tirer de ce rendez-vous de
singapour en mai c'est que le professeur
schwab a voulu sans doute marqué la nuit
d'importance nouvelles de l'asie dans
l'économie mondiale s'est en effet
le virage vers la vie qui a déjà été
marquée par les états unis dans le passé
et par un certain nombre de grands pays
alors est-ce que à singapour on fera des
progrès essentiel c'est possible hier la
chancelière angela merkel a parlé des
vaccins et elle a dit que bien entendu
il fallait que tous les pays et à
l'intérieur des pays toutes les
catégories de la population est un accès
égal aux vaccins on sait bien que ce
n'est pas le cas actuellement puisque
certains pays ont acheté ont préempté
sur le marché des vaccins que d'autres
ont des difficultés à se fournir
et que comme souvent les pays en
développement arrive bon dernier et que
leurs populations se trouve discriminés
contrairement à ce qu'avait promis le
secrétaire général de l'onu
contrairement à ce qu'avait promis
également le directeur général de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
et ceci est un problème important parce
que ils pourraient avoir un ressentiment
important de la part des populations
discriminées par rapport à cette
nouvelle inégalité et puis des
propositions ont été faites
la main tendue du profit du président
poutine à l'europe
et d'ici là il est probable que les
européens verront qu'elle répond si on
peut apporter
il est possible d'apporter une réponse
positive en effet en décidant de mettre
provisoirement entre parenthèses des
sujets qui fâchent ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on est d'accord ça veut dire comme on
dit chez les diplomates que l'on grille
tout 18 sur un certain nombre de sujets
et on l'aimé pour un certain temps de
durée indéterminée entre parenthèses on
progresse sur des sujets sur lesquels on
peut progresser et il est possible que
ce soit le cas d'ici le mois de mai
merci que le blanche maison d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes expert en relations
internationales
illustration de cet appel de vladimir
poutine à une meilleure atmosphère
générale premier entretien téléphonique
entre le président russe et son
homologue m
qu'un job hayden hier soir parmi les
sujets abordés le traité new start la
sphère navalni ou encore la situation en
ukraine
pierre jan masaryk un premier coup de
fil loin de réchauffer les relations
américano russes vladimir poutine et joe
biden se sont entretenus sur les sujets
qui fâchent le cas navalni la situation
en ukraine
nord stream 2 ou encore les récentes
cyberattaques contre des ministères
américains imputé par washington à
moscou
si du côté du kremlin on semble vouloir
calmer les esprits le ton semble plus
incisif du côté de la maison blanche le
président russe a noté que la
normalisation des relations entre la
russie et les etats-unis seraient
conformes aux intérêts des deux pays et
compte tenu de leur responsabilité
particulière dans le maintien de la
sécurité de la stabilité dans le monde à
ceux de la communauté internationale
tout entière
le président mbaye donne a clairement
indiqué que les états unis agirons avec
fermeté pour défendre nos intérêts
nationaux face aux actes de la russie
qui pourrait nous nuire
point positif des discussions
le traité new start sur la limitation de
l'armement nucléaire qui doit expirer le
5 février prochain
les deux puissances qui serait parvenu à
un accord pour le prolonger de 50 vaches
d'acheter aux aliénés element of il est
important qu'on ait réussi à préserver
un des éléments de l'architecturé
internationale dans ce domaine se
reflète la politique responsable de la
fédération de russie dans le domaine de
la maîtrise des armements qui est
essentiel que ce traité soit prolongé
pour une durée de cinq ans sans
condition préalable
nous comptons profiter de ce temps pour
lancer les négociations approfondies et
intense avec les états unis sur l'avenir
de la maîtrise des armements et preuve
que le temps presse
vladimir poutine a pris les devants en
soumettant un projet de loi sur cette
prolongation devant la douma le
parlement russe
un texte finalement ratifié par les
députés
elle parlement russe justement a donc
voté tout à l'heure la prolongation du
traité new start sur l'armement
nucléaire
une avancée importante sans pour autant
réchauffer réellement les relations
américano-russes florian lambert dernier
pacte majeur sur le contrôle des
armements entre moscou et washington
cet accord voté par la douma d'état
soulève l'espoir d'une amélioration du
dialogue entre les états unis et la
russie après un entretien avec son
homologue américain ce mardi au
téléphone le président russe a salué la
prolongation de ce traité je viens de
mentionner mon entretien avec le
président mbaye dernière et la
prolongation du traité start c'est
définitivement un pas dans la bonne
direction mais je le répète la situation
peut évoluer de manière imprévisible et
incontrôlable si bien sûr nous ne
faisons rien pour empêcher que cela se
produise les négociations avaient
soudainement cessé sous la présidence de
donald trump
ce dernier l'acceptant qu'une
prolongation d'un an
quelques jours après l'arrivée de joe
biden à la maison blanche moscou s'est
empressé d'acter la prolongation de
l'accord pour cinq ans un accord
également salué par l'union européenne
le chef de la diplomatie allemande salue
une décision qui constitue à ses yeux un
vrai plus pour la sécurité également en
europe et un premier signal de la
nouvelle présidence américaine sur la
scène internationale malgré cet échange
prometteurs dans les relations russo
américaines
moscou et washington n'oublie pas pour
autant les divergences passé à l'heure
actuelle il ne s'agit pas d'une remise à
zéro de nos relations
hier les deux présidents en constatant
qu'il existait des divergences assez
considérables ont tout de même souligné
la nécessité de poursuivre le dialogue
ce qui est déjà bien suffisant
cet accord sur le traité new start
marque en tout cas une première avancée
diplomatique entre la russie et les
etats-unis comme un nouveau départ
évoqué donc hier soir entre les
présidents russe et américain la sphère
alexeï navalni
la police russe multiplie les
perquisitions visant l'opposant
politique après son entourage se sont
aujourd'hui son domicile et ses bureaux
qui ont été à visiter ses proches
dénoncent une volonté d'intimidation
elle est inquiète en lien avec les
manifestations de samedi se succèdent
alors que les partisans d'alexei navalni
annonce de nouveaux rassemblements ce
dimanche un nouvelle journée de
manifestations dans plusieurs villes de
tunisie au lendemain d'un remaniement
ministériel contester les mobilisations
se succèdent depuis la mi-janvier une
dixième anniversaire de la révolution de
jasmin en cause les crises économiques
sociales politiques et sanitaires qui
secoue la tunisie malgré les annonces du
chef du gouvernement d'entendre les
revendications les manifestants ne
décolère pas le point sur place avec
notre envoyé spécial bassam chebbi
bassem à vous êtes en direct de tunis
comment évolue la situation mais plus
terrible est de plus en plus tendues
surtout depuis le vote de confiance qui
a eu lieu très tard hier au parlement un
parlement qui a été barricadée depuis la
veille par le gouvernement les forces de
l'ordre ont quadrillé le parlement et
toutes les rues adjacentes au parlement
beaucoup de manifestants avaient fait le
déplacement la comté et pu être d'un
millier scandaient des slogans hostiles
bien sûr à la police mais surtout au
gouvernement plus particulièrement au
parti ennahda le parti islamiste qui a
une énorme influence sur la politique du
miel et que les tunisiens dénoncent par
le lan parlera par leurs actions mais
surtout leur inaction vis-à-vis de la
population
beaucoup de jeunes étaient sur place et
les mêmes revendications que depuis le
premier jour de manifestations et de
tension qui a élu le 14 janvier dernier
je vous propose d'écouter quelques
réactions pendant cette manifestation
je suis venu ici pour réclamer les
libertés les droits et la justice
je suis venu aujourd'hui pour que tout
le monde soit ensemble
je suis venu ici aujourd'hui parce qu'en
tant que jeune cet état a dépensé pour
m'éduquer comme mes parents l'ont fait
pour que je réclame et droit
je suis venu en soutien à mes camarades
il y à la société civile présente et
nous sommes ici en soutien de nos
camarades interpellés
libérés les interpeller c'est l'autre
principal slogan aujourd'hui ces
différents mouvements sociaux ces
manifestations ne vont pas ralentir la
seule différence c'est que depuis
quelques jours beaucoup d'appels à
manifester sur des réseaux sociaux est
depuis aujourd'hui plus aucun appel à
manifester la raison est simple la
police traque tous les manifestants
toutes les personnes qui lancent des
appels à manifester sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est la raison pour laquelle ce
mouvement va continuer mais ça va a été
fait de manière spontanée des bouches à
oreilles sans dire où est ce que la mue
manifestation aura lieu et sans donner
plus de précisions énormément de
personnes ont été arrêtées la
manifestation d'hier on a compté plus
d'une centaine d'arrestations et depuis
le début de ce mouvement on a compté
plus de 1200 arrestations beaucoup de
jeunes beaucoup ont comparu devant la
justice
beaucoup de manifestants ont demandé la
libération de ces jeunes manifestants
aujourd'hui pas de manifestions les
manifestations à tunis mais beaucoup
dans le reste de la tunisie il faut
s'attendre à beaucoup plus de
manifestations dans les jours à venir
car la tension ne semble pas redescendre
en tunisie merci ben hassen chébili pour
toutes ces précisions direct de tunis
crainte d'une quatrième nuit consécutive
de violences au liban ce soir à
l'origine de ces contestations les
mesures strictes de confinement pour
tenter d'endiguer à la pandémie de kobe
de 19 mai dans ce pays en crise
la pauvreté est plus à craindre qu'une
coronavirus françois tisci reach
à tripoli des manifestants tentent de
mettre le feu au siège du gouvernorat de
la région du nord du liban
une nouvelle soirée de manifestations
contre les restrictions sanitaires
émaillée d'affrontements avec les forces
de sécurité
[Applaudissements]
jeudi dernier les autorités libanaises
ont décidé de prolonger jusqu'au 8
février
le confinement strict mis en place le 14
janvier un confinement qui s'accompagne
d'un couvre feu 24 heures sur 24 et
d'une fermeture des commerces uniquement
autorisée à livrer à domicile
pourtant lorsqu'on se rend dans l'un des
marchés de la ville de tripoli
nombreux sont les libanais bravant
quotidiennement les interdits une
question de survie pour les travailleurs
journaliers représentant près de la
moitié de la population active libanaise
car avec la terrible crise économique
qui touche le pays
restez à la maison est synonyme pour
beaucoup de familles ils nous ont ruiné
ils nous ont transformés en mendiants
on n'a plus les moyens de manger les
gens meurent les gens manche qu'il
trouve dans les poubelles
vous voulez acheter à manger et nourrir
vos enfants vous ne pouvez pas ils nous
ont détruit les tailles corrompu l'état
est une ordure l'état nous a rabaissés
au plus bas l'état autorisé des fêtes
pour le nouvel an et à gagner des
millions ils ont fait la fête
ils ont terminé ils nous ont dit
coronavirus et on ferme les magasins
nous n'avons rien à manger les autorités
libanaises assurent distribué 400 me
livre par mois soit environ 219 euros à
230 mille ménages défavorisés
un montant jugé insuffisant dans un pays
en proie à une inflation à trois
chiffres
de l'aveu même du ministre des affaires
sociales trois libanais sur cat aurait
désormais besoin d'une aide de l'état
dans un liban frappé depuis plus d'un an
par des restrictions sur les retraits
bancaires une dépréciation de sa monnaie
des licenciements massifs et des baisses
salariales
les retombées sociales du confinement
sont désastreuses d'après l'onu plus de
la moitié des libanais vivent
aujourd'hui sous le seuil de pauvreté et
près du quart dans l'extrême pauvreté
restez sur rt france dans quelques
instants retour sur l' annonce du jour
celle de gabriel attal pour le porte
parole du gouvernement le couvre-feu à
18 heures n'est pas suffisant pour
freiner l'épidémie
outre-manche pour itunes sont annoncés
qui le contraint désormais les voyageurs
revenant de pays à risque à faire leurs
dix jours de quarantaine à l'hôtel et à
leurs frais a tout de suite
[Musique]
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est des
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'il ya un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que que la france a été
plus mauvaise que beaucoup de nos payes
et étrangers nous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dont la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on va retrouver un équilibre en
faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
[Musique]
alors que l'économie mondiale à plonger
les bourses elles elles tiennent le coup
un rebond forcément en mars après la
chute importante est tout à fait naturel
mais la hausse qui a poursuivi n'est
absolument pas en relation avec
l'économie aujourd'hui il faut tenir les
marchés à tout prix et pour les tenir
bien vous déversez des liquidités vous
avez une banque centrale qui fixe les
prix on est dans un régime de prix
administre l'on voit finalement une
bourse qui continue de progresser malgré
les mauvaises nouvelles
il va maintenant falloir surtout
retrouver cette corrélation entre
l'économie et les marchés financiers
marchés financiers sont boostés boosté à
la dette boosté à l'argent qui est
imprimé par la banque centrale est la
principale conséquence c'est la
disparition de la valeur de la monnaie
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gars fall de l'apli cas-là
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et non line quel
rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu
les big for donc les gaffes à
s'organiser pour annuler quelqu'un sur
internet ce quelqu'un c'était donald
trump quand il s'agit d'un bannissement
si général pour moi ce n'est pas aux
gaffes à et aux réseaux sociaux à
dolhain des entreprises privées de
prendre cette décision mais ça doit être
à la justice de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose alors gens
font-ils
tout
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il ya quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
je
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission a permis
d'identifier trois mille victimes 1500
agresseurs ces chiffres sont forcément
très en deçà de la réalité puisque des
victimes sont décédées des victimes ne
peuvent pas parler peut-être ne
parleront jamais ça montre cette
tragédie qui lie à un système au tour
c'est-à-dire comment des agresseurs
ont-ils pu agresser 10/20 parfois trente
ans nous sommes loin du bout du chemin à
vous savez des institutions se réforment
lentement l'église peut-être encore plus
lentement je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas je pense que la prise de conscience
est fait de tels scandales de tels
drames de telles tragédies dans la vie
oblige à la vérité
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise
lorsque c'est arrivé cette histoire
personne ne prenait pas au sérieux nos
pieds il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
compris a pris les choses en main mais
c'est presque inévitable que l'on met
tout le monde dans le même panier et à
dire que la boîte de nuit le bistrot de
quartier à quelles conditions pierre
gagna allons nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les
restos c'est pas les clés mon jeu je
produis je travaille je sais cette faire
au mieux c'est aussi tout un
questionnement sur la société sur le
rapport à la solidarité et le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre le manque dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois s'il faut un
évidemment
[Musique]
vous
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que c'est fini pour moi est ce
que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
on
[Musique]
il est 21h heure française excellente
soirée à toutes et à tous si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france place à une
deuxième heure d'information tout de
suite les titres de ce mercredi 27
janvier
le mot n'est pas lâché mais le couperet
risque de tomber le porte parole du
gouvernement prévient un au film en très
serrés fait partie des scénarios
envisagés l'issue du conseil de défense
sanitaire de ce matin est sans appel le
couvre-feu ne freine pas suffisamment la
propagation du cornât virus
emmanuel macron demande des analyses
supplémentaires sur le variant anglais
avant de décider situation délicate
également ailleurs en europe la norvège
ferme ses frontières à presque tous les
non résidents pas de confinement en
espagne malgré la hausse exponentielle
des cas de kobe de 19 depuis trois
semaines outre-manche place à une
quarantaine à l'hôtel pour les arrivées
de pays à risque le royaume uni qui a
dépassé hier les cent mille morts liés
aux strass cov 2
[Musique]
une première en france l'état a mis en
demeure par un collectif des ong pour
mettre fin au contrôle d'identité
discriminatoires par la police
emmanuel maintenant avait reconnu en
décembre leur existence six
organisations saisirons la justice et le
gouvernement n'apporte pas de réponse
satisfaisante dans les quatre mois le
président de la transition malienne reçu
aujourd'hui à l'elysée par emmanuel
macron une visite qui intervient après
celle du chef d'état tchadien idriss
déby la semaine dernière et ce alors que
se profilent en février le prochain
sommet du g5 celle lors de ses
traditionnels voeux aux armées le
président français avait ouvert à la
voie à une réduction des troupes
françaises dans cette région
[Musique]
couvre-feu insuffisant c'est la
conclusion du conseil de défense
sanitaire de ce matin plusieurs options
sont sur la table pour contrer le
coronavirus et ces variants confinant
souple confinement dur quand pour
combien de temps c'est toute la question
baïla séraphin le couvre-feu à 18 heures
est entrée en vigueur le 2 janvier dans
15 départements jusqu'à sa
généralisation de semaine plus tard les
premiers résultats positifs se font
visiblement attendre le couvre-feu à 18h
à ce stade en effet une efficacité
relative qui est réel mais qui n'est pas
suffisante
à ce stade c'est donc en anticipation
avant de tirer les conclusions au bout
des deux semaines que nous envisageons
plusieurs scénarios les effets
définitive du couvre-feu seront mesurés
cette semaine sur le plan national la
situation épidémique témoigne d'une
circulation active du virus et de ses
nouveaux variants un plateau haut qui
augmente une incidence qui augmente une
pression sur l'hôpital qui augmente
une diffusion des variants qui est à
l'évidence importante et rapide et c'est
dans ces conditions que nous avions
appris en anticipation le couvre-feu
avancé à 18 heures évidemment les
spéculations vont bon train si gabriel
attal n'a pas manqué de souligner la
lassitude de beaucoup de français un
troisième confinement strict pourraient
être considérées alors à quel scénario
faut-il s'attendre ce sont plusieurs
scénarios qui vont d'un maintien du
cadre actuel avec le couvre-feu à 18h
jusqu'à un confinement très serré et que
dans le même temps des concertations
vont être menées par le premier ministre
à la demande du président de la
république avec le comité de liaison
parlementaires les groupes
parlementaires représentés au parlement
avec les partenaires sociaux et les
associations d'élus
ces concertations approfondies vont se
dérouler dans les tout prochains jours
une seule alternative a été
définitivement rejetée imposer un
confinement aux personnes âgées n'est
pas une option envisagée par emmanuel
macron à lyon se dérouler aujourd'hui un
nouveau procès de décrocheurs du
portrait d' emmanuel macron le militant
écologiste charles
lacombe comparaissait pour avoir
décroché en 2019 le portrait officiel du
président de la république installé dans
la mairie de villeurbanne
ils entendaient dénoncer l'inaction du
gouvernement en matière d'écologie
luis carballo avec clément barbet cette
photo prise en 2019 portrait d' emmanuel
macron en main vaut à charles ii
lacombre d'être convoqué pour la
première fois devant la justice
cet ingénieur de 26 ans comparaissait
devant le tribunal correctionnel de lyon
pour avoir pris part à la campagne
décrochons macro objectif dénoncer
l'inaction du gouvernement français face
à l'urgence climatique les actions
décrochage de portraits aujourd'hui
elles sont plus que jamais d'actualité
puisque deux ans après le début de la
campagne
et bien en fait emmanuel macron et son
gouvernement sont toujours aussi
hypocrite un double discours qui est
plus présent que jamais des objectifs et
des engagements qui centrait dans tous
les sens avec aucun acte qui suit malgré
la peine encourue sept ans de prison et
100 mille euros damende le militant
écologiste ne regrette pas son geste
oui s'il fallait aujourd'hui à nouveau
décroché un portrait évidemment ça
serait toujours pertinente parmi les
dizaines de personnes venues le soutenir
avant l'audience des citoyens des
militants mais aussi plusieurs élus dont
cette adjointe à la mairie de
villeurbanne ville où charles lacombe
avait décroché le fameux portrait
quand même
une urgence climatique qui est là
maintenant les conséquences de
désastre écologique pour les a
aujourd'hui ça commence déjà c'est pas
demain et du coup l'action maintenant
après une heure d'audience le procureur
de la république a requis 500 euros
d'amendé contre le militant la décision
a été mise en délibéré au 1er mars 2021
un éventuel à nouveau confinement les
français ils seraient de moins en moins
favorables on y revient c'est ce
qu'indique un sondage est là pour bfm tv
publié aujourd'hui seuls 52% des
personnes interrogées se disent
favorables à un confinement similaire au
précédent alors qu'ils étaient 93 % en
mars dernier et 67 % en octobre
les personnes de moins de 50 ans semble
être celle qui s'oppose le plus à cette
mise sous cloche confusion donc au sujet
d'un éventuel reconfirme on en parle
avec jean françois bach immunologue et
secrétaire perpétuel de l'académie des
sciences
bonsoir jean françois bach merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
après cette énième conseil de défense
sanitaire le flou persiste on a du mal à
y voir plus qu'il tout clair les
français sont perdus emmanuel macron
demande des analyses supplémentaires sur
la prévalence du variant anglais avant
de prendre des décisions cette souche b
1-1 certains comme elle se nomme
réellement c'est quoi c'est une épidémie
dans l'épidémie comment est-ce que s
circulent sur le territoire français non
je ne dirais peut-être pas une épidémie
dans l'épidémie parce que c'est à fait
courant dans des épidémies virales qu'il
y ait des mutants qui évolue donc c'est
une dérive un peu de l'épidémie c'est la
première importante et pas forcément la
dernière
non ce qui se passe c'est que ça change
le rythme de l'épidémie et ce qui est
bien sûr difficile gérer c'est qu'on ne
sait pas absolument à quel rythme si ça
s'accélère vite les comprends pas des
mesures a fait rapidement
or il est débordé et inversement c'est
pas aussi grave qu'on prend on risque
d'en faire trop ou alors c'est tellement
sensible beaucoup de niveaux que vous
avez évoquées il faut évidemment caf a
beaucoup dit faire demain 10 à 15 %
quand même 20% angeli annan tout à
l'heure qu'on avait
en invité le chef réanimation de
l'hôpital de guerre je parlais de 20%
des tests positifs aux copies de 19 qui
seraient des variants issus des variants
anglais
vous dites on ne sait pas quand cette
souche remplacera la souche initial on a
un ordre d'idée quand même et lorsque ce
sera effectif quelles seront les
conséquences
alors il en parle on peut on ne peut
parler que de ce qu'on connaît qui est
maintenant établie c'est que le taux de
présence de ce variant va augmenter il
va d'ailleurs pas forcément augmenter de
la même façon dans toutes les régions de
complication supplémentaire mais enfin
il va augmenter des modélisations
indique qui va ta prof 42 ans et alors
c'est pas forcément beaucoup plus grave
ce moment c'est ce qui est ennuyeux
c'est que ça va augmenter le nombre de
cas chaque individu elle ne sera pas
pour demain mentalement différent des
cas précédents cas chauffe et cela a été
suggéré par le premier ministre anglais
met ses doigts d'être établi donc sauf
événement extraordinaire de la maladie
reste la même j'ai simplement parler de
du premier ministre britannique boris
johnson
il a dit que ce variant pouvait être
potentiellement plus mortelle mais votre
avis d'immuno lag est ce qu'on se
retrouve face à un nouveau virus qu'on
ne connaît pas pardonnez moi
l'expression mais ce qu'on va encore
devoir trimballer la population d'une
annonce à une autre avant de démentir
ces annonces ici ou là
alors le problème j'avais fait que dans
tout cela il ya la fiancée la politique
je m'occupe de là je vois bien les
l'embarras des politiques de ma patte à
leur place c'est très compliqué et les
problèmes en angleterre ne sont pas au
royaume uni en général soient pas les
mêmes qu'en france parce qu'on royaume
uni ils ont un nombre de cas
considérables qui sont vraiment devant
problème plus difficile que l'autre
aujourd'hui mais donc moi je partirai
des principes qu'aujourd'hui dans l'état
actuel des connaissances il n'est pas
démontré que ce variant donne des formes
plus sévères que le virus que nous avons
actuellement cela dit il il se plus
contagieux donc le nombre de cas la
courbe d'augmentation en risque d'être
plus rapide
lequel a été dans les vagues précédentes
c'est ça le problème
vous dites il n'est pas démontré je me
permets de revenir sur sur les vaccins
coudes et des vaccins puisque les
sorties médiatiques des scientifiques
notamment disent les études qu'on a ne
montre pas que les vaccins ne sont pas
efficaces mais les scientifiques ont
disparu mais mais vous ne dites pas
aller les études montrent que les
vaccins sont efficaces la négation elle
est importante dans les déclarations
parce qu'au final ça montre qu'on sait
pas grand chose
non ce qui a été montré ce que l'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est que il ya deux choses
différentes à la gravité de la maladie
par elle-même indépendamment des faits
bon là je vous dis y'a pas de raison de
penser aujourd'hui qu'elle sera pire a
même s'il ya plus de la deuxième
question f que les vaccins qui sont
utilisés aujourd'hui pour protéger les
sujets vaccinés décliner contre ce
variant britannique et la réponse on a
des éléments de réponse important la
réponse est oui
ce qui n'est pas absolument le cas au
même niveau pour les autres variant sud
africain ou brésiliens les poules
variant angles et maintenant on peut
dire que effectivement les vaccins vont
protéger ses concurrents oui c'est
rassurant mais vous parlez d autres
varaillon vous avez parlé de variants
sud africains brésiliens dont on a
évoqué le variant angles est évidemment
il ya le variant californien maintenant
elle s'en sort plus à quand le variant
bretons corses savoyard quoi oui oui
novem les raisons c'était de
complications cette épidémie pour les
autres ce que l'on sait actuellement
c'est que il y a peut-être sans doute on
n'a pas les chips étaient tout récent
tout ça ça fait quelques quelques jours
il semble que pour le baril au-dessus
d'africains de la protection apportée
par les vaccins et arn messager et
témoin bonne elle existe toujours mais
elle est moins bonne et titre des
anticorps sont moins bons alors à partir
de ça est ce que ça va diminuer la
protection apportée par les packs chaque
nous avons actuellement contre ces
variants sud africains brésiliens
on ne sait pas encore vraiment mais
c'est une possibilité alors que ce n'est
pas une possibilité pour le variant
britannique assurait être à se re sur ce
point et puis un autre élément quand
même qu'il faut pointer un peu des
inscrits c'est que la technologie des
vaccins et l
que si c'était nécessaire si vraiment
les personnes n'avaient pas toute leur
efficacité contre les variants aux sud
africains et brésiliens ou d'autres qui
pourraient exister
il est assez facile de refaire un vaccin
par derrière dans quelques mois
donc ça c'est une bonne nouvelle mais
après se posera évidemment la question
de la logistique de la production et ce
sont d'autres considérations évidemment
merci beaucoup jean françois bach
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes immunologue
secrétaire perpétuel de l'académie des
sciences
sachez que la majorité ait l'air em a
voté la fin de la mission d'information
de l'assemblée nationale sur la gestion
de l'épidémie de kobe 19
les oppositions dénoncé un coup de force
et une absence de débat contradictoire
ailleurs en europe beaucoup d'inquiétude
également au sujet des variants la
norvège ferme ses frontières à presque
tous les résidents l'allemagne menace de
suspendre ses liaisons aériennes en
espagne pas de confinement mais un
couvre-feu sur tout le territoire alors
que le nombre de contamination augmente
depuis trois semaines les précisions de
leslie cinglage journaliste indépendante
à barcelone les restaurants et les
commerces sont ouverts dans la plupart
des régions d'espagne mais les
établissements sont soumis à des mesures
différentes selon la communauté autonome
par exemple en catalogne les restaurants
sont fermés le soir et les commerces non
essentiels le week end dans la
communauté de valence l'hôtellerie peut
proposer uniquement des plats à emporter
et les espagnols sont également soumis à
des restrictions de mobilité du côté de
madrid
il est interdit de se réunir à domicile
et d'ailleurs dans la capitale il ya
quelques jours une manifestation s'est
tenue pour protester ce sont les
négationnistes qui ont défilé sans
masque pour demander plus de liberté
laissez nous respirer ont-ils scandé
alors le pays poursuit en parallèle sa
campagne de vaccination le retard de
livraisons de doses a contraint les
régions à repenser à leur organisation
madrid et la catalogne réserve les doses
restantes pour les administrés aux
personnes ayant déjà reçu la première
dose et un nouvel espoir rené en espagne
grâce à un nouveau médicament la pythie
des psys développé par leur un
laboratoire espagnol
il permettrait de diminuer de 99% la
charge
du coup rona virus le médicament est
donc pris très au sérieux
le laboratoire attend le feu vert pour
passer à la dernière étape de l'essai
clinique
au royaume uni la barre des 100000 morts
dus coronavirus est désormais affranchie
depuis hier une première en europe
actuel premier ministre boris johnson
dit assumer les voyageurs revenant au
pays de pays à risque sont contraints
d'effectuer dix jours de quarantaine à
l'hôtel et à leurs frais hélène
masculine
c'est le premier pays européen à passer
le triste cap des cent mille morts le
royaume uni est lourdement frappée par
cette troisième vague qui en a fait le
cinquième pays le plus endeuillé au
monde depuis le début de la pandémie en
proportion son bilan sanitaire est plus
élevée même que celui des etats-unis ou
du mexique
l'heure est venue pour le premier
ministre boris johnson d'endosser son
rôle de leader face à l'hécatombe
derrière les chutes ghost je tiens à
répéter que je suis profondément désolé
pour chaque vie perdues et bien sûr en
tant que premier ministre j'assume la
pleine responsabilité de tout ce que le
gouvernement a fait qu'augmenter ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que nous avons
vraiment fait tout ce que nous pouvions
et continuera à faire tout ce que nous
pouvons pour minimiser les pertes de
vies ans blaye 1 et les souffrances dans
ce qui a été une étape très très
difficile et une crise tout aussi
compliqué stage un manque de préparation
décision tardive de nombreux experts et
associations du pays pointent du doigt
les autorités pour leur gestion de
l'épidémie
mais c'est aussi l'apparition du variant
britannique le kent identifié fin
septembre qui a marqué le début de cette
déferlante
avec près de 1000 morts quotidiens
ducobu 19 ces dernières semaines et les
hôpitaux surchargés accueil 78 % de
malades du court aux navires us de plus
que lors du pic de la première vague au
printemps dernier ces hausses records
met à mal le service de santé du pays
déjà soumis à une énorme pression en
dépit de la campagne de vaccination car
si le royaume uni a déjà vacciné près de
7 millions de personnes
le nombre de contaminations lui peine
encore à baisser il semble qu'ils
diminuent très légèrement dans certaines
régions notamment à londres dans le sud
est et l'est du pays
mais il ya des régions où ils ne
diminuent pas encore de manière
convaincante
il est donc toujours à un niveau très
élevé dans tout le pays et le personnel
du national health service est
particulièrement sollicité avec de
nombreux patients très touché par les
symptômes de la maladie en europe le
variant britannique inquiète les autres
pays qui cherche à tout prix à éviter un
scénario à l'anglais zh
hier soir l'allemagne a mis en
quarantaine près de 3000 employés d'une
clinique de la ville bavaroise de bail
ruth après la détection d'un possible
foyers épidémiques berlin qui envisage
même de fermer son espace aérien en
provenance de l'international et en
direct de grande bretagne
baratta pangkhan ya expert en maladies
infectieuses à l'université d'exeter
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
bonsoir par encana merci de répondre à
nos questions sur arte france au
lendemain des accusations de boris
johnson qui dit avoir fait ce qu'il a pu
quel est l'état d'esprit des
britanniques
est ce que c'est un constat un aveu
d'échec et est-ce qu'ils sont inquiets
les britanniques est ce que l'inquiétude
monte young inc non je ne pense pas que
nos hommes politiques sont assez mûrs
pour admettre et reconnaître qu'ils ont
échoué qui n'ont pas fait un assez bon
travail
we call of the back-up beaucoup de
facteurs auraient pu être retraités nous
aurions dû faire mieux
cent mille personnes sont mortes au
royaume c'est à dire que cent mille
familles sont en deuil sont stressés
sont en colère il est donc important que
notre gouvernement reconnaisse que ce
n'est pas seulement 108 personnes
dc c'est 5000 familles et même encore
plus donc il faut vraiment qu'on
reconnaisse leur colère leur frustration
qu'on comprenne pourquoi les choses ont
mal tourné au royaume uni et
l'inquiétude est ce qu elle grandit car
nous sommes en situation de configurer
il est donc difficile de jauger l'état
d'esprit mais je suis l'association il
est prêt ce qui m'inquiète c'est le
niveau de colère dans les communautés de
frustration ainsi que le niveau de
chômage et où beaucoup de moyens de
survie tout cela annonce des problèmes à
venir à temps 6 9 12 mois
c'est un problème de très grave à
l'horizon il est très important que le
gouvernement s'en rendent compte et
réduit les tensions au sein des
communautés
vous venez de parler du look down
les anglais qui sont donc confiné quid
des mesures sanitaires
est-ce qu'il faut un durcissement aux
frontières à ce que ce serait suffisant
est-ce qu'il faut imposer le port du
masque à l'extérieur au royaume-uni
puisque c'est pas le cas en ce moment
avec tous les variants qui arrive elle
voir un anglais on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure avec jean françois bach le
variant sud-africain californien
brésiliens etc
quelle mesure sur l'anjou en tant qu
expert en maladies infectieuses il
faudrait prendre toutes les mesures
avaient déjà wave mans se parler et le
faire à quelqu'un qu'il faut donc leur
thé des masques effet technos il faut
porter des masques de kon tum emporter
partout il y a plusieurs personnes mais
c'est donc dans les supermarchés dans la
rue lorsqu'il ya beaucoup le port du
masque
ce masque de paternité est porté dans le
passé nous avons su porter des masques
de moeurs qualité l'été bout de tissu
maintenant nous sommes face à un variant
plus contagieux qui circulent au est
minuté comme européenne donc nous avons
besoin de mesures carrières plus
efficace où les contaminations
continueront pour parler de ce variant
britannique plus contagieux à boris
johnson a évoqué une mortalité peut être
plus élevé au final c'est quoi c'est une
épidémie dans l'épidémie parce que quand
on entend les différents scientifiques
vous êtes un scientifique
on entend souvent les vaccins on
l'évoqué tout à l'heure avec avec jean
françois bach
on n'a pas de preuve comme quoi les
vaccins ne serait pas efficace on
utilise toujours cette négation mais on
ne dit pas les vaccins sont efficaces
ils le seraient sur le variant
britannique mais on ne sait pas sur les
autres variant brésilien californien sud
africain et c'est donc le fait
d'employer cette cette négation ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on ait perdu
qu'on ne sait rien c'est ça on repart
dans une nouvelle épidémie et on repart
dans l'inconnu non ayew est peu d'âme et
non dans une épidémie comme et je
souhaite rassurer et vaccins aujourd'hui
il compte en effet sur les variants
également ce n'est pas entendu je note
que même si varié en mer même si la
protée de spie qu est très différente du
beau jeune homme va créer un combat
nouvelle version du vaccin afin de
lutter spécifiquement contre le variant
donc ce n'est pas un problème en soi
le problème c'est qu'effectivement ces
variants plus contagieux comme lui
contait juin nous devons renforcer nos
mesures de contrôle de la contagion du
risque et évitement des foules
évidemment des lieux de la proximité par
exemple dans le jeu ou les transports
publics
donc ces mesures avec la vaccination
nous aideront donc vous êtes rassurant
d'un certain côté puisque ce que disent
les scientifiques et sont unanimes on
peut
modifier le vaccin pour qu'elle soit
efficace sur ces variants mais après ça
posera évidemment la question de la
logistique y ont voient la logistique en
ce moment il est très compliqué où on
est d'ailleurs la campagne de
vaccination outre-manche parle beaucoup
de retards de livraisons notamment en
europe le fait que le vaccin astrazeneca
et l'université d'oxford soit fabriqué
en grande bretagne c'est un atout pour
vous britannique alors que l on le voir
un bruxelles c# avec les laboratoires
ce sujet notamment avec astrazeneca donc
on l'a vu tout à l'heure il est
originaire de vaccins il est extrêmement
j'ai changé un look 100 a gagné
nous ne sommes pas encore là mais
seulement il est impossible que nous
n'ayons jamais le coran qui ne vaccinent
pas si rapidement après le premier
vaccin en tout cas être considérée comme
une famille que ce soit le royaume uni
où les européennes il ne faut pas
éliminer chacun de son côté la bonne
solution serait de vacciner le monde
entier tout d'un coup
simultanément sinon il pourrait y avoir
de gros problèmes à l'avenir
allons comme ils facturent in africa par
exemple la contagion
la filiale russe pourrait monter en
afrique ou même dans d'autres pays tels
que le brésil ou à l asie et ensuite le
virus pourrait revenir vers l'europe
occidentale où est le royaume lui donc
il est dans notre intérêt d'aider ces
pays pauvres ou de nouveau de nouvelles
mutations pourraient apparaître
merci baratin pangkhan fière d'avoir
répondu à nos questions depuis
l'université d'exeter en grande bretagne
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
maladies infectieuses autres pays
européens autre tour de vis inédit celui
ci si les britanniques sont confinés en
slovaquie depuis aujourd'hui un test
qu'ovide négatif est obligatoire pour
sortir de chez soi et la médiane
déambuler dans la rue se rendre chez le
médecin ou faire ses courses
une seule règle prouvées de sa
négativité au cours aux navires us
une nouvelle mesure qui s'appliquera
jusqu'au 7 fait
riez prochain pour toutes personnes
âgées de 15 à 65 ans près d'un slovaque
sur deux a été testé en une seule
semaine
résultat 30 mille personnes positives
face à la flambée du nombre d'infections
les autorités vont plus loin désormais
les salariés doivent montrer patte
blanche sans le document négatif
impossible donc de reprendre son travail
avant de pouvoir travailler nous avons
dû envoyer le certificat notre employeur
et aux ressources humaines de ce que
j'entends
d'autres entreprises contrôlent
également leurs employés des firmes it
encore les personnes les moins
vigilantes s'expose d'ores et déjà à de
lourdes amendes
la police prévient elles peuvent
atteindre jusqu'à 1000 euros
de quoi forcer certains à s'adapter
rapidement nous devons nous adapter
j'ai besoin de travailler donc je dois
me faire tester le mois prochain les
zones du pays à taux d'infection plus
élevé subiront une nouvelle série de
tests massif
les autorités slovaques refusent de
miser sur les seuls vaccins compte tenu
des problèmes d'approvisionnement
à rester sur rt france on se retrouve
dans quelques instants pour un gros plan
sur une première en france une action de
groupe a été déposée contre l'état par
un collectif des ong pour mettre fin au
contrôle d'identité discriminatoires par
la police puis on parlera du président
de la transition malienne reçu
aujourd'hui à l'elysée par emmanuel
macron en toile de fond le prochain
sommet du g 500 dans trois semaines au
tchad a tout de suite
[Musique]
l'état islamique a recruté dans toutes
les couches de la société sans faire de
tri des mineurs des femmes des
délinquants des criminels de droit
commun tout le monde est venu à jaca en
syrie il ya encore quelques quelques
années au moment de charlie hebdo l'eau
ou du bataclan il y avait un état
islamiste qui semblait diriger tout ça
la bascule et se fait justement en 2015
et semis et c'est un peu le passage de
relais d'al qaïda l'état islamique
quelque part dans notre politique
internationale vis bien évident qu'il
faut pas créer les conditions à nouveau
une terre de kia de cet appel d'air
justement au recrutement l'a
malheureusement fait en syrie en irak
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes le sang et les larmes on
les a déjà trop de dépenses trop d'état
je pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique et est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productive
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gaffes à ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom est en ligne quel
rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu
les big for books les gaffes à
s'organiser pour annuler quelqu'un sur
internet ce quelqu'un c'était donald
trump quand il s'agit d'un bannissement
si général pour moi ce n'est pas aux
gaffes à et aux réseaux sociaux à des
entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
de retour sur arte france il est 21h30
heure française l'info continue
juridiquement la démarche est inédite
six ong et associations ont lancé
aujourd'hui une action de groupe
objectif obliger l'état à prendre des
mesures pour lutter contre les contrôles
d'identité jugé discriminatoire dans un
premier temps le gouvernement est mis en
demeure d'agir 1 faute d'action dans les
quatre mois un juge sera saisi un
dispositif largement inspiré des class
actions ce qui existe dans les pays
anglo saxons amnesty international
propose également d'enregistrer les
contrôles et leurs données après des
années de travail sur les
discriminations par les forces de
l'ordre en france et ailleurs les
organisations appellent à la mise en
oeuvre d'un ensemble de mesures
elle exige notamment la création d'un
système d'enregistrement et d'évaluation
des données relatives aux contrôles
d'identité et de mise à disposition de
toute personne contrôlée d'une preuve de
contrôle alors quelle solution l'état
peut-il mettre en place quelle solution
satisfaisante selon les termes même des
organisations
c'est le face à face
[Musique]
nos invités louis georges tin président
d'honneur du cran le conseil
représentatif des associations noires de
france et antoine villedieu secrétaire
national du syndicat france police
policiers en colère et délégué
départemental rassemblement national en
haute saône
bonsoir messieurs mais avant de venir
vers vous on vient de l'entendre amnesty
international réclame l'évaluation des
données relatives au contrôle d'identité
le moyen d'aboutir à des statistiques
parce que regarder les dernières dates
de 2016 ont été réalisés par jacques
toubon l'ancien défenseur des droits
cette fois plus de contrôles pour les
18-25 ans cinq fois plus de contrôles
pour les sommes perçues comme noirs ou
arabes donc une probabilité 20 fois plus
élevée que les autres d'être contrôlé
votre réaction louis georges tin et bien
que tous les travaux scientifiques vont
dans la même direction
qu'il s'agisse des travaux du défenseur
des droits les travaux des scientifiques
des travaux internationaux en france
c'est la même conclusion
il était sur représentation des noirs et
des arabes dans les contrôles et même à
l'époque monsieur hortefeux qui n'était
pas connu pour être un anti raciste
patenté avait reconnu l'existence de ce
fait il était ministre de l'intérieur
cette class action je m'en réjouis
d'autant plus que c'est le cran qui a
brûlé la campagne pour mettre en place
ce dispositif législatif et qu'il faut
effectivement que les associations s'en
saisisse parce qu'aujourd'hui la
difficulté le métier de policier très
dur mais il sera encore plus dur si
effectivement il y a une certaine
impunité vis-à-vis de faits de violence
et des faits de racisme qui
malheureusement sont légion on les voit
tous les jours il y a eu des milliers de
personnes au dégoût facebook sur l'été
révélée par mediapart il ya eu des
violences pendant les gilets jaunes
l'onu s'est saisie de ce dossier et
jusqu'à présent c'est l'impunité totale
pour l'impunité est inacceptable a
fortiori dans un métier qui tu dois être
exemplaire
voilà pour aujourd'hui pourtant l'igpn
est quand même saisir 2
de nombreux dossiers vous antoine
villedieu comment est-ce que vous
accueillez cette mise en demeure de
l'état sur n'est pas une instance
judiciaire et l aise dans une pitié de
futsal sur ces dossiers c'est une vaste
blague cette institution et c'est pour
ça que le dossier n'avance pas et donc
quand on est juge et partie
forcément ça donne ce genre de résultats
c'est à dire que vu ça nulle
voilà pourquoi les associations sont
obligés aujourd'hui de porter l affaire
devant les tribunaux
antoine villedieu votre réaction alors
moi lestienne international et cinq
autres associations mettent en demeure
le gouvernement dans les quatre coins de
modifier les règles de contrôle au
faciès
effectivement nous le comprends pas on
voit pas on va pouvoir rester là on a un
cadre qui est très précis sur le
contrôle d'identité c'est le 78-2 du
code de procédure pénale
c'est des contrôleurs directions
complètement encadrer la police ne
choisit pas sa délinquance
la police est au service de tous longs
mois la police que je connaisse c'est
pas la police que monsieur teint en
train de décrire moi c'est une police
issus de la diversité
c'est une police et qui ne regarde pas
la couleur de peau quand elle doit
intervenir ou protéger une population et
c'est une beau pull et c'est la police
aussi dans les quartiers sensibles où
les contrôles au faciès sont ses plus
importants sur une commande hier
population d'origine immigrée qui en
fait pourrissent la vie au quotidien à
des habitants qui eux mêmes sont
d'origine il irait donc en fait moi
c'est un discours que je comprends
absolument pas
tout ce que je vois c'est que ça fait
quelques quelques mois que beaucoup
d'associations
beaucoup de responsables politiques
veulent racialisée que le débat public
et c'est la meilleure façon c'est de
créer une fracture entre la popul la
population et la police
pourtant à entendre villedieu emmanuel
macron avait déjà avoué en décembre
dernier la possibilité de contrôles
discriminatoires
souvenez vous avait déjà parlé pareil en
demie
l'enquêté qui a été menée par le
défenseur des droits et excusez moi de
dire ça mais pour moi il n'y a aucune
légitimité puisque les statistiques
ethniques
ils sont totalement
hardy en france donc aujourd'hui on se
base un petit peu sur des spéculations
sur des enquêtes de terrain mené par des
organismes qui ont déjà un parti pris
donc il faudrait dans ce cas là
autoriser les statistiques ethniques
dans leur globalité
mais dans ce cas là ce serait un autre
départ aujourd'hui on cherche pas à
diviser la population française on sait
qu'on cherche à rassembler tout le monde
toujours dacia les discours c'est
toujours aussi mettre en opposition deux
parties et c'est pas c'est parce que
l'on cherche
messieurs je vous propose de voir ce
qu'avait a dit emmanuel macron le 4
décembre dernier
aujourd'hui quand on a une couleur de
peau qui n'est pas blanche
on est beaucoup plus contrôlés on est
identifié comme un facteur de problème
et c'est insoutenable
avec cette déclaration louis georges tin
est ce qu'on peut dire que le président
se désolidarise des choix de la police
six y est je crois que le président dit
la vérité parce que tous les travaux
scientifiques le disent et de voir un
représentant d'un syndicat de police
être encore dans le déni quand tous les
travaux scientifiques français
internationaux disent la même chose je
me dis c'est ça le problème c'est le
déni et lorsqu'on refuse de voir kylie a
évidemment partout des gens bien et des
gens pas bien que ce soit parmi les
jeunes de quartiers ou parmi les
policiers mais de contester l'existence
du délit de faciès
quand même monsieur hortefeux le
reconnaît qu'en l'état il reconnaît
quand la cour de cassation a déjà
condamné je le dis des policiers pour
contrôles au faciès donc la cour le dit
le président le dit le défenseur de
droits de 10 les scientifiques le disent
la seule personne qui conteste cela
aujourd'hui ce sont certains syndicats
de police eh bien le problème il est là
lorsqu'on a une position de déni
systématique
évidemment on ne peut pas avancer et
après des policiers s'étonne qu'il y ait
des jeunes qui déteste la police je
déteste pas la police mais jeudi qu' il
y a dix policiers qu'une position
détestable parce que ils nient
l'évidence qu'il ya des jeunes
délinquants c'est évident il faut les
arrêter mais qu'il ya des policiers
délinquance est aussi une réalité
le racisme est un délit et nier ce délit
c'est extrêmement fâché quand vous avez
par exemple des milliers de policiers
qui sont dans des groupes facebook qui
tiennent des propos racistes
jusqu'à présent il n'y a pas eu la
moindre exclusion il n'y a pas eu la
moindre sanction administrative
monsieur est ce que votre syndicat a
condamné les personnes qui avait tenu
ces propos à ma connaissance non donc
s'ils voulaient c'est quand même
hallucinant
le racisme est un délit vous avez des
milliers de délinquants qui sont
policiers ou gendarmes
cela est révélée sur mediapart et ces
gens continuent le groupe existe
toujours et c'est l'impunité la plus
totale
jeudi nous sommes dans un pays dont la
devise est liberté égalité fraternité
l'égalité n'est pas respectée et donc la
police n'est pas respectée en fait
lorsqu'on refuse de sanctionner des
policiers qui donnent une mauvaise image
de la police on entretient finalement
ces amalgames en entretient l'idée que
tous les policiers sont racistes alors
que ce n'est pas tout les policiers mais
qu'en revanche qui est systémique
c'était pas le racisme dans la police
c'est la protection des racistes car
vous savez l'article 40 du code de
procédure pénal dit que tout
fonctionnaire qui est témoin d'un délit
à l'obligation de dénoncer donc il y à
des policiers raciste des policiers
raciste mais il ya tous les autres qui
ne disent pas ce qu'il en est qui
devrait entendre des façons son complice
mois en fait j'ai rejoint un peu
inquiétant sur le fait qu' aujourd'hui
ceux qui dénoncent le racisme dans la
police principalement sont surfaites qui
ne font pas partie de la police puisque
les syndicats et police en défend une
ligne et qui est très claire aujourd'hui
tous ceux qui sans fil qui s'insurge
contre le racisme dans l'institution
c'est tous des gens fait qu'il n'y a que
toi pas qu'il n'y a que toi panis au
quotidien ni en interne
moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
la police ait une grande diversité
elles recrutent dans tous les domaines
dans tous les milieux sociaux quelle que
soit l'origine la commission religieuse
ou autre
aujourd'hui la police à voir ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure à côte on
intervient on ne regarde pas la couleur
de peau des individus
maintenant il ya un moment donné il faut
aussi être face aux réalités les
réalités c'est quoi c'est que vous avez
une concentration de délinquance à
certains endroits qui sont pour la
plupart des quartiers populaires vous
avez des points de deal qui sont tenus
par des fois par des personnes de
couleur
deux fois qu'ils sont totalement blanc
qui on veut rentrer dans ce discours un
petit peu d'opposition
ça n'empêchait n'empêchera pas de
contrôle y ait autant la personne
blanche que la personne de couleur parce
qu'il ya un lieu il ya un passif sur
l'endroit
il ya des comportements qui ne laisse
pas penser qu'à un moment donné ils sont
en train de commettre une infraction
ces gens là il faut aussi comprendre
qu'ils pourrissent la vie je leur ai dit
une deuxième fois mais des habitants de
ces quartiers qui eux mêmes sont issus
de l'immigration
donc il ya un moment donné je veux bien
j'entends parler du jour du défenseur
des droits il tient sa position vous
tenez votre position avec votre
association nice tient à internationale
fait aussi son travail mais moi
aujourd'hui j'ai rien compris entre les
mains je n'ai pas de statistiques
ethniques pour vous dire oui la police
et plus comment dire contrôler plus au
faciès une personne d'origine immigrée
qu'une personne d'origine blanchi juste
qu'il ya des secteurs avis qui les
secteurs à risque malheureusement
aujourd'hui ce sont des quartiers
sensibles
on suit ce type mais si on reste plus
beaucoup de temps j'aimerais j'aimerais
vous vous questionnez sur le bobo de la
sécurité du nom évidemment de la place
ou qui abrite le ministère de
l'intérieur ce bobo de la sécurité et
débute lundi
cécile coudriou la présidente d'amnesty
international a déclaré aujourd'hui
qu'elle regrettait que les ong n'y sois
pas invitée vous partagez cet avis louis
georges tin oui c'est évidemment coup
pour rien le sujet qui est évoqué au
départ c'étaient les veaux liant les
violences policières et le racisme dans
la police
or d'abord les associations qui portent
ce combat ne sont pas invités au premier
scandale
deuxièmement j'entends que le syndicat
alliance nous dit qu'un jour avant le
début du mouvement
que tous ces revendications août accepté
on est un peu surpris donc ya pas deux
il ya déjà des conclusions avant même
l'ouverture du débat
et troisièmement me dis que les
policiers aient bien leurs frais de
distance de transport votre pris en
charge
bon je suis content pour eux moi je suis
plutôt favorable à ce genre de vie de
mesures je vois pas très bien le rapport
avec la police en plus une mesure qui
risque d'être discriminatoire par
rapport aux autres fonctionnaires
donc c'est un peu bizarre de lutter
contre les discriminations par les
discriminations par rapport par ailleurs
je rappelle à monsieur que les
statistiques ethniques ne sont pas
interdites en france contrairement à ce
qu'il a dit deux fois ce sont les fiches
techniques qui sont incertains sertic
donc ce soit des statistiques monsieur
du coup je vous demande est ce que vous
estimez aujourd'hui si je vous suis bien
que brice hortefeux
le président de la république
le défenseur des droits le cnrs la cour
de cassation qui l'ont maintes fois
confirmé l'existence du délit de faciès
que tous ces gens ont tort et que vous
seuls avez réseau est ce que c'est ce
qui est en train de dire aujourd'hui
parce que c'est ce que j'ai cru entendre
oui aucun problème je vous dis que les
policiers de la police aux violences je
vais mèneront à tort s'en fout mais bien
ça au moins c'est clair
bon ça s'est passé est-ce que vous
l'aviez vous avez déjà portée parce que
vous savez ce que c'est lui et pelletier
est ce que vous me connaissez vous savez
là vous avez déjà été contrôlé au faciès
certainement pas donc moi je vous dis je
ne parle pas de mon expérience de loire
je ne parle pas de votre expérience de
policiers messieurs on n'arrivera pas de
toute façon à vous mettre d'accord c'est
la fin de ce face-à-face merci merci
beaucoup louis georges tin d'avoir
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le président
d'honneur du cran le conseil
représentatif des associations noires de
france
merci également à vous entre une ville
dieu vous êtes secrétaire national du
syndicat france police policiers en
colère et délégué départemental et
rennes en haute saône une opération
militaire conjointe entre paris et
bamako a permis de neutraliser une
centaines de jihadistes dans le centre
du mali annonce faite hier par l'armée
malienne une annonce qui intervient à la
suite de l'élimination de l'élimination
d'une vingtaine de terroristes la
semaine dernière par les forces
françaises et leurs partenaires locaux
plus de détails en images
[Musique]
dans ce contexte le président de la
transition malienne bas ndo a été reçu
aujourd'hui à l'elysée par emmanuel
macron sa première visite en france
depuis son entrée en fonction le 25
septembre dernier à la suite d'un coup
d'état
un déplacement d'une durée de trois
jours au programme des discussions la
coopération franco malienne ainsi que la
préparation du sommet du g5 prévu
n'djamena avec la capitale du tchad les
15 et 16 février prochain
on en parle avec apam sont brouillées
ainsi ses membres du conseil national de
transition le cnt bonsoir gbagbo ici
c'est merci de répondre à nos questions
avec l annonce de la mort d'une centaine
de djihadistes au cours de l'opération
éclipse mené par les forces françaises
et maliennes
la mission barkan est-ce qu'elle redore
son blason bonsoir oui effectivement on
espère que ce genre d'émission va
perdurer
parce qu'il y avait une certaine
lassitude de la part des maliens ce
qu'on savait après huit ans de après
l'engagement de la france lors de
l'opération serval il ya en santé une
situation d'enlisement et aujourd'hui
dieu merci on voit que il ya une montée
en puissance et que cette opération
conjointe à et des résultats probants et
on espère enfin que ce genre d'émission
va perdurer dans le temps et bouter les
terroristes hors du du territoire malien
est généralement du sahel la région
justement du sel on rappelle un qui
regroupe cinq pays mali tchad burkina
faso mauritanie niger est ce qu'elle est
suffisamment sécurisé pour envisager un
retrait progressif des forces françaises
puisque emmanuel macron l'a évoquée lors
des traditionnels voeux à l'armée
florence parly la ministre française
désarmé l'a dit également pour t'en
souviens il ya environ un an à pau il y
avait un sommet
et la france envoyait 600 hommes
supplémentaires dans la région
oui bon en un sens c'est en tout cas le
ressenti sur le terrain fait
qu'aujourd'hui le retrait des forces
étrangères n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
et quand on voit où elle est liée à 10
qui continuent de circuler librement
dans dans des verres au mali au niger au
tchad en mauritanie au burkina
je pense que le retrait de la france
elle doit ce prêt doit se préparer et
doit ce programme et qu'on nous laisse
le temps de monter en puissance au
niveau notamment du g5 du cei et aussi
des forces mondiales puisque moi je
parle en tant que malien mais le
président ne précipitons pas les choses
laissons le temps au temps je comprends
un peu la lassitude de des français mais
aussi de quelques mois dernier
oui la france doit s'en aller mais non
la france va ça n'allait dans des bonnes
conditions et le laisser un pays
sécurisé mais pour l'instant parce que
la situation est quand même bien changé
en un an une cinquantaine de soldats
français tués au sahel
oui exactement donc cela tue c'est à
dire que les opérations sont menées
si on perd des hommes sur le terrain
c'est une délibération de sang mêlé donc
ça signifie au smic malheureusement que
la situation sécuritaire n'est pas
encore aussi loi pouvait l'espérer il ya
la force européenne également apte à
kouba déploiement d'unités d'élite
européenne qui doit prendre le relais de
la force barkan dans la région est ce
qu'elle peut suffire à assurer le
maintien de la paix au sahel et au mali
notamment que vous représentez oui je
pense que la faute à kouba et les forces
du g5 du sahel six continents et si même
les mêmes actions connu il reste on
obtiendra des résultats probants
on a vu lorsqu'il part calme et les
forces maliennes se met en scène vous
avez vu il ya une centaine de de dia dit
stud alors si c'est plutôt un contingent
européen et maliens qui se mettent
ensemble on aura oui des résultats
probants
ça j'en suis certain on l'a dit les pays
du g5 sahel se réunissent les 15 et 16
février à n'djamena la capitale du tchad
qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre de ce
sommet qu est ce que vous vous vous
attendez le cnt le conseil national de
la transition malienne j'espère que nous
allons y arriver
en tant qu'africain si bien d'avoir de
l'aide d'experts extérieurs mais à un
moment donné il va falloir compter sur
nous mêmes il va falloir que le juge ait
cinq minutes
en fait en puissance et que le g5 sera
réellement déployés sur le théâtre des
opérations
on ne peut pas toujours compter sur la
france où les unités européennes pour
nous sortir de cette situation
il est temps que les pays du sahel se
donnent la main et puisse permettre aux
jeunes d'avoir les moyens financiers
techniques pour combattre les dyades y
seront sur leur territoire on l'a dit
tout à l'heure
bein daul le président du conseil
national de transition que vous
représentez a également a été reçue tout
à l'heure par emmanuel macron à l'elysée
en france une visite de trois jours
qu'est ce qui va se passer exactement
pendant ces trois jours pour votre
président ou en est là la transition
politique au mali alors la transition
politique se passe très bien
les trois organes exigé par la cedeao
ont été mises en place dont 80 de la
république
un vice président de la république fin
chef de l'état et le gouvernement
et aujourd'hui je suis membre du cnt le
conseil national de transition qui
devient l'organe législatif donc oui la
transition s'ils sont pauvres
il reste encore 13 à 14 mois pour
essayer de mettre le mali sur de bons
rails quant à la visite du président de
bada ou en france c'est qu'il visite
attendue et naturel je dirai ce que
quand on connaît l'histoire entre ces
deux pays là est d'autant plus
l'histoire récente il est normal que les
présents de la transition
sierentz euros sur place pour une visite
de travail et il est à la villa à paris
dans ce cadre
merci à bam se mouiller si c'est d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes membre du conseil national de
la transition malienne le reste de
l'actualité avec twitter et la
modération des contenus certains
trouvent le réseau social trop laxiste
d'autres trop censeurs le géant du web a
alors inventer un nouvel outil pour
lutter contre la désinformation piloté
par sa propre communauté
katia pique nique twitter s'est doté
d'un nouvel outil expérimental contre la
désinformation présenté le 25 janvier il
s'appelle bird watch surveiller les
oiseaux plutôt d'ailleurs les vilains
petits canards
twitter a déjà mis en place une
modération effectuée par des
professionnels et prévient les
utilisateurs qu'un contenu est une
fausse information et renvoi grâce à un
lien sur un contenu fiable vérifier
scientifique mais avec birds watch
twitter s'appuie cette fois sur sa
communauté
il ne s'agit pas là de censurer
l'information trompeuse mais d'apporter
des éléments de contexte
écoutons les explications du vice
président de twitter qui coleman les
usagers apprécient que les notes
viennent de la communauté
et plutôt que de l'autorité centrale de
twitter et le fait que les notes apporte
du contexte pour les aider à comprendre
et évaluer un tweet plutôt que de se
concentrer sur des étiquettes comme vrai
ou faux comment cela va-t-il se passer
si un internaute repère un tweet
trompeur il pourra cliquer sur une icône
dédiée est le signe avait on pourra
classifier le type de fausses
informations par exemple c'est une
blague qui est considéré comme une
véritable info ou encore c'est une
allégation non vérifiés puis devra
ajouter une source fiable qui contredit
le tweet histoire d'étayer son
signalement avec une vérité est prouvée
alors quels sont les risques de ce
nouvel outil participatif contre la
désinformation que des trolls ou autres
propagateurs de fait qui news vienne
infesté bird watch de commentaires
fallacieux contre cela twitter va mettre
en place un vote du type ce commentaire
at il été utile pour départager les avis
farfelues des propos sensés un outil de
ce type aussi être utilisé par des
militants politiques pour décrédibiliser
leurs adversaires mitraillant de
commentaire autre écueil à redouter la
prolifération de commentaires bird watch
a ajouté aux nombreux commentaires déjà
existants de quoi se perdre en
digressions infini à la manière des
débats que l'on retrouve sur les notes
de wikipédia on écoute la vie de cyril
d'allemands spécialistes du numérique
tout à diluer les limiers de sa
rentabilité avec un système
communautaire en volant père portait en
fait une part de cette responsabilité là
divisés entre eux mais les différents
intervenants mon pull et des différents
utilisateurs de twitter qui participants
et de a retrouvé un petit peu de sa
superbe pour expliquer qu'avec cette
démarche finalement c'est pas à l'organe
décisionnel de twitter qui prend la
décision a priori à ces réseaux sociaux
on diffuse des informations diffusent
des messages diffusent des contenus
collecte des informations sur des fêtes
sur des territoires nationaux
c'est au rôle de
l'état et la justice de cet état de
déterminer clairement ce que ce qui est
possible de dire et ce qui n'est pas en
tout cas twitter longtemps accusée de ne
pas modéré suffisamment ses contenus
resserre les boulons
il vient d'annoncer qu'il retirera les
badges bleu pour les comptes twitter
incomplets ou inactifs comme celui
visant estampillé les organismes
médiatiques financé par un état comme le
nôtre et les priver de visibilité mais
attention hein pas les grandes chaînes
publiques de france ou de
grande-bretagne certains étant plus
égaux que d'autres
twitter a supprimé le compte de donald
trump après des monceaux de fait qui use
de la part de l'ancien président mais le
réseau a aussi suspendu les comptes de
féministes françaises qui avaient posé
il ya quelques jours cette question bien
légitime en plein débat sur l'inceste et
l'âge du consentement
comment faire pour que les hommes
cessent de violer twitter est bien moins
prompts à supprimer les images de
pornographie et de violence qui
prolifèrent sur son réseau dans le vaste
champ d'ordures déversés chaque jour sur
twitter certains contenus monopolise
toute l'attention dommage
c'est la fin de cette émission merci à
amélie béguin cyrielle benavides bullion
à david luiz inouïe
aux équipes techniques de jean charles
valentin et de mathieu voltz évidemment
ce soir on se retrouve d'ici quelques
minutes pour 1 point complet sur
l'actualité rester sur arte france
évidemment à 38 ans
[Musique]
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise lorsque c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux nos pieds il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris a pris
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier à
quelles conditions pires gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restos c'est
pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille et je sais c'est de faire au
mieux c'est aussi tout en questionnant
sur la société sur le rapport à la
solidarité et le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre donc dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois s'il faut un
évidemment
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
alors que l'économie mondiale à plonger
les bourses elles elles tiennent le coup
un rebond forcément en mars après la
chute importante est tout à fait naturel
mais la hausse qui a poursuivi n'est
absolument pas en relation avec
l'économie aujourd'hui il faut tenir les
marchés à tout prix et pour les tenir
bien vous déversez des liquidités vous
avez une banque centrale qui fixe les
prix on est dans un régime de prix
administre convoi finalement une bourse
qui continue de progresser malgré les
mauvaises nouvelles
il va maintenant falloir surtout
retrouver cette corrélation entre
l'économie et